why do philosophers love death it's a
good question as to why philosophers
love death and it's essentially because
it's a main orientation point for
meaning because faced with
ultimate loss it then asks you well what
is important while you're alive
and so facing death facing finitude or
your own
mortality then becomes a central uh
sort of way to frame yeah what is it
what is a good life and I think
certainly a lot of people are curious
about that what does it mean to have a
good death
um it's a good question about what it
means to have a good death there's it's
been a fascination of a lot of
philosophers of well it's to be you know
surrounded by people and it's to be you
know have a legacy and
um and I think a lot of cynics have also
there's a book about
um all of the ridiculous ways that
people have died
um and so I think that largely has has
become more of a
um a sort of joke within philosophy of
uh that that you know there's all this
Obsession about having a a a good death
and ultimately you know what does it
amount to and what does it really matter
why does it really matter
um I forget who it was but there was a
general who was really trying to have
this you know good death and and he was
he was bleeding out and um he was trying
to get all of his men uh uh to come
together before before he passed and
they weren't
coming together fast enough and he knew
he was gonna die and he just blurted
tell them I said something great and
then died
and so I think
stories like that seem to have kind of
taken the main that it's like well let's
talk about life itself rather than you
know what it is to die because you
really have no control over it if
someone has a story idea and they never
write that story
does their story idea even matter
it's a good question
if somebody has a story idea I would say
it
just made it seem harsh but I would say
it doesn't matter
I think ultimately what's real is what
you put into the world and but even if
you just write it down right like Emily
Dickinson she had hundreds of thousands
of poems that never were published but
once she passed people found them and
then those were out into the world and
those took on and and you know a whole
kind of world of meaning was built
around her and and what she created and
so I I really am a strong advocate of
always you know putting things down and
taking action and you know and creating
because that's if it's just in your head
then it's it's it's not it's not yet in
the world and so
um I always try to get as much out out
as possible
is that something that plagued you
because it sounds like you've always had
these these ideas or or been drawn to
things that were maybe ahead of your
time
um I think for me yeah there was a sense
early on of
what it is to be great and to have a
legacy and
um
and
certainly to sort of like
uh establish yourself and and sort of
beget success from that and so
um but I think as far as kind of linking
with ideas ahead of my time or
um
I think it was more always came from
within is like what is it that I want to
say and I want these paths to open up
further for me so that there's less
inhibitions that I can write down an
idea and then go to investors and get a
project going and just kind of move move
move
because there's never a shortage of of
ideas for the next film and there's
probably you know 15 projects that I've
got you know Brewing at different stages
and so it's more a bit about sort of how
to converge that momentum
in order to uh yeah be be out there more
in the world and expressing and working
with people that I love to work with
when you were studying uh philosophy at
UC Berkeley
was that your goal then to go into
directing and producing films or did you
not know exactly what you wanted to do I
always knew I was a Storyteller and that
that was you know my path in my life and
um and specifically studying philosophy
at Berkeley was to understand the power
of story
and I had I loved horror films and so I
kind of asked like well is that what I'm
gonna do is you know just make horror
films while climate change and all these
other you know things are happening and
it was philosophy that sort of
regrounded the value and
um kind of went back to the very basic
questions of uh faced with these
problems what can one do and sort of
allowed me to sort of rebuild my
um sort of world of meaning and sort of
get more concrete on values and
um to better understand the the power of
story and that was you know through
existentialists and
um you know read a bunch of Dostoevsky
and kirkegaard and um and and then I
came back and I was like okay you know I
feel like now there's I'm not I'm not
waiting in the water you know that
there's a solid infrastructure around me
that I can I can you know build future
projects and build build my career on
top of
why not go to film school and just
you know learn how to
write the next you know fun teen comedy
I I had made so I started making films
uh really in like elementary school and
then so by the time I was in college I
had well by the time I was in high
school I had already been taking film
classes at College
um learned screenwriting and production
and just kind of basic things and I was
enormously self-taught so every
documentary about filmmaking every you
know behind the scenes I could get my
hand on commentaries
um and so then when it turned to going
to film school I felt like it was
doubling up and I also took Umbridge
that the schools sometimes own your
films and I thought why am I going to
pay a massive amount of tuition to also
pay uh to make my own films if I feel
like I already have that knowledge and
it felt like it was doubling up so I
thought how can I sort of
extend my knowledge of filmmaking and
storytelling and and that led me to
philosophy what differentiates a movie
that has a great message a good message
from a movie that's too preachy
a film that's too preachy I think can be
too just heavy-handed on an audience and
essentially your immediate reaction is
is like well you've it feels more like a
rhetorical argument it feels like you're
at dinner and somebody's saying like you
should believe this
uh whereas
a film that I think just has a message
is for me kind of like interacting it
you know with somebody at dinner and
they're saying like well this these are
the things that are important to me and
these are the this is the way I see the
world and um and this is the way I think
you know one might consider a situation
like this
um versus do this be that uh and and so
that in my films while they do have
messages
um I'm always very uh conscious of not
having it to be too heavy-handed how
does a movie effectively present a point
without insulting the intelligence of
the audience
I mean in in any film you know as a
director you're always asking yourself
okay this is this is what I'm showing
visually and what is the audience going
to take away from that
and I always try to
assume that the that the audience is is
smarter than I am and not kind of you
know hand feed them things certainly
there's Parts where uh you know if you
need to connect dots but
I always assume that people will be
smart enough to get things and if they
aren't then they'll ask the per you know
the person next to them in the theater
um and it I do really think it's it's
important to not
um speak down to your audience or or to
you know be be too kind of heavy-handed
um in in storytelling because
it can easily lead to an eye roll which
then pulls people out
and I would rather people be asking and
engaging and uh uh sort of drawing
people further in together about hey can
you clarify this can you clarify that
um rather than saying uh well I feel
like I'm you know in a uh in a film
that's that's for kindergartners or
something like that
sure so it may be better to leave with a
sense of mystery where where there's
like people can't exactly figure out
there's an ambiguity to it yeah so I
watched a ton of um Sydney lament's uh
voice so I watched a town of Sydney
lamet's
um commentaries he actually has a
commentary for every single film he's
ever made and one point that comes up
over and over and over is the Cutaway
is uh say you have somebody who really
wants to be invited to a party and they
get an invitation and they open it
do you cut away to the invitation or do
you say the audience is smart enough
they know that he opens the envelope and
he's been invited and so that level of
of Distinction and I'm on I'm on the
same camp is that you don't have to
spoon feed every bit of information the
audience is very smart and will be with
you and so then you can move on to the
next scene where he's actually at the
party because we we get the point right
can you explain how stacking the deck in
favor of a message is cheating the
audience
and how stacking the deck against your
message is challenging the audience and
ultimately hitting deeper truths
so in constructing a film that
ultimately has a message and you're
wanting to
uh
I feel like if you're wanting to sort of
lead the witness or
um
philosophical terms like use a straw man
argument that it is pretty disingenuous
because essentially
um
I mean we all know why leading the
witness is is not a great idea uh but I
think in filmmaking you can run into a
similar concern where
if you want to show somebody something
there's so many ways to do that
um there's so many brilliant films that
that do that but if you're wanting the
film to draw a conclusion then
[Music]
uh
if for me it sometimes just feels like a
bit disingenuous a bit um like a
rhetorical argument
rather than having a conversation it
feels again like you know being a bit
condescending to the audience that you
can kind of trick them into thinking
this or that and uh
um I just feel like it's in in bad faith
and so in constructing narratives I'm
always sensitive to to that point as
well
um that um you know you're you're not
manipulating and that you're not uh
um doing anything further than saying
you know consider this and and see this
and step into this this other world
has that happened where you've you have
footage you have a rough cut on the
editing timeline and you realize oh no
this is this is a rhetorical question
and we've got to go in and and fix it or
or is that something that you be that
you're they're cognizant of when you're
shooting and it doesn't normally happen
generally it's in the way the film is
structured or framed in the beginning
um but it certainly can come out in
nuanced decisions as we're working
through
um
you know in our film seven days in Syria
for example
uh we were conscious that we're really
showing one side and that was because we
didn't have access to the other side and
so you know we we put little bits and
pieces in the film itself to acknowledge
that and
um uh and just kind of cue to the
audience that like you're seeing this
perspective you're not seeing the
perspective from the other side
um and that was just again to sort of
you know give give proper context uh to
an educated audience about about how to
interpret and watch this film
because essentially it was a story of a
female journalist who wanted to go over
there and was told don't do it yeah and
and but essentially we also were on the
free Syrian Army side so it was mainly
the the rebel Army that was you know
um going against this you know very
dictator dictatorial regime
um and
you know the troubling statistic was
that 80 percent of of Syria at the time
was in favor of the of this dictatorial
regime which is you know just killing
people left and right who are opposing
them
um and so you know but that wasn't our
full perspective we were to sort of walk
you into a window into this other world
and what it is what it's like to live
during wartime
I believe some of the footage was from
other people's cell phones and you you
gave credit to them yeah exactly so we
we pulled uh basically when we were in
Aleppo uh there were different people
that we met along the way and then we
incorporated their footage as well
um other other journalists other you
know people that were just civilians
um and use that to kind of build a more
holistic picture of of
um of what life in in Aleppo before it
had fallen was was like
and did anybody say anything about they
felt it was one-sided or not uh
certainly there's
um certainly there's some comments
online and uh not with my film but
basically uh pro-russian pray Pro Syrian
uh uh people have tried to hack accounts
for their film and tried to try to
disparage it in all these different ways
because eventually essentially what
you're there is you're showing what it's
like to be a human being and those who
are trying to oppress those human beings
are usually at least in these cases
backed by governments and have their own
budgets and they sometimes you know do
that to try and censor